this week's cover story is in defense of
the Silicon Valley tech bro and our
model is our resident tech bro tope
who's here right now
so Soto can you tell us a little bit
about what it's like being like a tech
bro in like the modern day well it's
incredibly exciting and but also a lot
of responsibility because it's like like
basically we're atlas and and we're not
gonna shrug you know because never
before has there been everything so
everywhere instantly all the time so we
got a lot of pretty good shots out of
the shoot we have a swung shot of you
kind of holding an iPhone in the Kindle
and you sort of you sort of look a bit
sad what were you sad at the moment or
what exactly was going to ahead and it's
it's just a piece of [ __ ] okay
yeah it's probably things like just the
profundity of what we're trying to do
yeah destroying everything old to make a
new world and then we had a great
close-up shot of you where it looks like
your eyes are closed but you're sort of
interacting with the Google glass Lee
well it's like once you'd become
familiar enough with the technology just
kind of like becomes part of it's almost
like your peripheral vision you know and
it's like it's like you might not be
seeing that exactly but you like know
what's there we actually settled on this
fantastic shot you're holding some Blue
Bottle coffee cups yeah I mean I drank a
lot of coffee razor scooter
yeah I gotta like commute and like get
around cities I'm not do brain right
yeah but like honestly most of the time
I'd like to get around the office yeah
and actually this is you have your cute
friend she looks like but yes oh yeah it
has a GoPro strapped to his head oh that
that's cool
so the story goes into sort of all the
negative stereotyping that's happening
in Silicon Valley culture he's kind of
arrogant men or very self-important and
think they're you know always thinking
mr. Cheney in the world but it also
talks to some people who are actually
making a real positive
some people's lives for the rest of the
magazine we have a feature on Paul
singer who kind of forced
Argentina to go to default we have an
exciting feature on the super producer
of Mike will lose a lot of artists
including Miley Cyrus singers are like
irrelevant you know okay and is there
anything else you read in a magazine
that you enjoyed mmm is there anything
you read in the magazine that you
enjoyed uh I don't really read statics
well despite that it's a great great
issue